as we said in the press
that i was invited to speak to the
transgender employees of netflix and i
refuse
that it's not true
if they had invited me i would have
accepted it although i am confused about
what we are speaking about
i said what i said and boy i heard what
you said
my god
how could i not
you said you want a safe working
environment at netflix well it seems
like i'm the only one that can't go to
the office anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
i want everyone in this audience to know
that even though the media frames us
that it's me versus that community
that is not what it is
do not blame the lbgtq community for any
of this [ __ ] this has nothing to do with
them it's about corporate interest and
what i can say
and what i cannot say
for the record
and i need you to know this
everyone i know from that community has
been nothing but loving and supporting
so i don't know what all this nonsense
is about
in summer 2020
[Music]
when the whole world shut down
i was outside
doing shows
my neighbor had a cornfield and he let
me throw shows there and people came
from all over the country some people
came from around the world
to see those shows the best comedians
on earth
came to my home and broke bread with me
and we lived our lives we found a way to
keep moving forward
i made a whole documentary about it
the first night of those shows was a
piece that some of you might have seen
it was called 846 and have dealt with
the death
the murder
of george floyd
this film that i made was invited to
every film festival in the united states
and some of those invitations i accepted
and when this controversy
came out
about to close up
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals and now
today
not a film company not a movie studio
not a film festival nobody will touch
this film thank god for teds randalls of
netflix he's the only one who didn't
cancel me yet
to the transgender community i'm more
than willing
to give you an audience
but she will not summon me
i am not bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to but i have some
conditions
[Applause]
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end
you must come to a place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly
you must admit that hannah gatsby is not
funny
[Applause]
i desperately want people to see this
movie
but i understand why investors would be
nervous since nobody will touch it i'll
tell you what i'll do
i will make it available
for all of you in 10 american cities
going on sale in the next few days
you will be able to see this movie in
its entirety and you can see what
they're trying to obstruct you from
seeing
and you can judge for yourself but you
cannot have this conversation and
exclude my voice from it
that is only fair
you have to answer the question am i
canceled or not
then let's go thank you very much and
good night